Let's look at the solution to our
coherence definition quiz where we had
two cores running in a coherence
system executing some code, and
the question was basically which
of these five possibilities for
what gets printed are possible?
Let's see what can happen
in these two programs.
If core 1 gets to go first with A = 1,
it's then going to spin here for
as long A = 1.
So, it gets stuck until
core 2 does something.
Eventually however,
core 2 will do A =0 in which case,
Core 1 gets to continue and
now core 1 will set A to 1.
Core 2 will wait here until
A is set to 1, because
as long as it's set to 0, the way it
set it, it's going to get stuck here.
So what then happens is Core 1
when it sets this releases core 2.
Now core 2 can do this and this first,
while core 1 is still being delayed
here or it can be that core 1 gets
here first and then core 2 gets here.
So definitely these two
outcomes are possible.
They basically depend on after core
1 waits for core 2 to release it and
then it itself releases core
2 who gets to print first.
Now let's see if it's possible for
core 1 to never get to this point.
For that to happen core 1
needs to get stuck here
in this while loop which means
that A needs to stay 1 forever.
That can only occur if core 2
is done with its program, and
the resulting value of A is still one.
Or if Core 2 also gets stuck here, and
So, Core 1 is stuck here, and A is one.
If that happens before Core
2 gets to A equals zeron,
then Core 2 is going to release Core 1.
So A = 0 had to happen before this.
If A equals zero happened
before all of this,
then what happens is A equals zero,
A equals 1.
Now we are stuck waiting for 1,
but core 2 will continue and
it has to see the one,
because this is a coherent system.
Eventually, because A equals one
happened after A equals zero,
core 2 has to see the one and proceed.
Once it proceeds, it's going to set
A to zero, core 1 has to see that,
because of the second part of
the definition, and proceed.
So it's not possible to get
core 1 start here by just moving
the A equals zero to the beginning.
Now let's see if it's possible for
CORE 2 to finish the whole
thing before this happens, in which
case CORE 1 will get stuck here.
But that's not possible
because CORE 2 now
needs to execute this whole program
here before CORE 1 even begins.
That's not possible, because core 2
sets A to zero, and then waits for
it to become nonzero.
So core 2 cannot finish the whole
thing until core 1 does at least this,
at which point we are back to the first
case of pretty much core 1 will
eventually see that the A 0 because core
2 set it that way after A became one.
It's also important to notice it's not
possible for example A equals one and
A equals two to happen
one after the other and
then core 1 thinks that
this was the last write.
So it gets stuck here while Core 2
thinks this was the last right and
then gets stuck here.
Because the third part of the coherence
definitions says that both
of them have to think that
the same access was the last one.
So if they agree that this was the last
one then this core gets released and
then ends up releasing the first one.
If they think this was the last access,
then this core gets to be released, and
releases the second one,
so either way, it's not possible
to get any of the three printouts.
In an incoherent system,
it can easily happen that you get
these or any of these other three?
So for example,
nothing can be printed then by simply
storing 1 to the cache and then
never really checking anything else,
just looping on the value
in the cache here.
Meanwhile, this one stores
another value in its own cache,
then just infinitely spins on it and
then you can get the other two
possibilities here by simply one of
them not being entirely incoherent.
So, as you can see,
a coherent system prevents some of
the behaviors that are possible
in an incoherent system.
But all the behaviors that are possible
in the coherent system are also possible
in an incoherent one.
So coherence is allowed
in an incoherent system.
It's just that incoherent
systems don't guarantee that
all their behaviors
are going to be coherent.